the possibility of a second Scottish
independence referendum are we watch
closely across Europe of course and
nowhere more closely than in the Spanish
region of Catalonia I've been speaking
to the region's foreign minister Raoul
ROM ever when you have a complex
situation the more normal thing to do is
to ask people what they think about and
to put arguments on the table that
exactly what we would like very much to
do on the situation you see parallels to
you between the Scotland or Long Island
and Catalonia
I see parallels in terms of democracy I
see parallelisms in the fact that there
is a complex situation there is a
political problem and from that
perspective needs a political solution
and indeed there is some circumstances
that make the Catalan reality a bit
parallel to what other really is notably
the one in Scotland are similar in fact
the fact that there is a population that
is we willing and that wishes to take
let's say the command or it's on its own
fate this is this is something that is
similar but there are some differences
the fact that in in Scotland there there
is a situation where you have a
government the UK government that allows
to have that debate and it makes it
possible and that even participates on
that debate defending its position
legitimately and this is not the case in
Spain that exactly would we are missing
and that's why we are very my jealous of
the situation in the UK in terms of the
month that's the big question though in
both cases is why break up these are
countries that have been living as part
of one nation peacefully together what
what why have a break up well I don't
just creating more boundaries actually
is the contrary because I'm not thinking
in terms of breaking up I'm thinking in
terms of democracy and thinking in terms
of making political projects more
reliable to the people when you have the
80% of the population in a country that
is putting in question the legitimacy of
the static War I think that means
something and they you should listen to
that obviously
there is a lot of opportunities in front
of us but I think that in any case what
you have to do is to confront reality
and reality right now in Catalonia is
that there is an 80% of the population
that understands that there is a
political problem that needs to be
solved democratically is that creating a
venturi I think it's exactly the upside
because the fact that you impede this
population to express himself in the
sense they wish it I think that's
created in Scotland the population
expressed its will and all that happened
was those people who wanted independence
just said ok let's have another vote but
that would that happen in Catalonia do
you think if if you lost on the first
round well but the question is that well
the situation has changed I mean the
something has happened in the case of
the UK and : something important which
is directed vote as well in the case of
Catalonia we are very much kin to ask to
the people and to respect the people's
wish which means that would the result
be
yes Catalonia should be an independent
state obviously these need to be
respected if the response is no as it
was the case in Scotland or in the
Quebec twice well this will have to be
respected as well and that's the problem
is never ended or maybe not
no because actually when you have a
complex situation the best way to tackle
this is to confront it democratically
situation is not going to disappear
simply because it's uncomfortable for
some and that would we always try to
explain to our friends in Spain that is
something that is on the table let's
talk about that that would you call here
the elephant in the room we would like
very much talk about that elephant
unfortunately we cannot do this in a
normal way with the Spanish state
institutions right now as you say the
Spanish government doesn't want to open
up this question it's also said that
were Scotland to become independent
the Spanish government would then block
Scotland from rejoining the European
Union do you think that's likely
well I think that first of all any any
situation is completely different to the
other Scottish case Israel is like there
is a link in one aspect is Britain
nowhere that these would be the final
outcome this is going to be negotiated
is written nowhere that a new state that
is part that is born within the European
Union will have to apply from outside
he's not written anywhere you can
interpret the text it's that way but you
can interpret them also in the other way
around so at the end is a question of
negotiations that's exactly what we want
to put the debate and that's basically
something that brings us to a situation
that you cannot simply permanently deny
reality reality is there and then it
forces you to tackle it and to face it
well how's the view from Catalonia
breaking news a lot